okay so here's something we talked about
last week the return of the miz senior
golden year's pageant over improv it was
awesome now before i tell you who won
the evening started with a poem from the
reigning queen lorraine babbitt
someone wonderful magical and sweet
will be crowned this evening
to make this day
from past contestants and members of the
silver tappers in costumes showing off
the paris of yesteryear theme to a
thrilling tribute to the folly bergere
and a serenade from fan favorite bill
watson i know i promised you the
tantalizing swimsuit portion of the
pageant
cameras were snapping all around the
showroom of the saddle west casino truly
a difficult task for me and fellow
judges mary mancini and phyllis truman
and in the end m.c stephanie elliott
miss senior golden years usa
marla
hello yeah real quickly i want to
mention the other contestants there's
laura horn brenda faye bolton sharon
crisp shelly fuller a sixth contestant
val hallam she wasn't feeling well
enough to participate when she was in
the audience cheering the other girls on
good and you guys i have to give a shout
out to the firecracker who makes the
whole pageant happen she's the founder
she's the president bj hetrick she's
only 96 years young is that it that's
all oh man and she's she kicks butt out
there it was awesome
great
i love those swimsuits
what was it like you were one of the
judges obviously you must have been you
mentioned how difficult the decisions
were yeah what kind of experience so we
had the interview and their platform
where they talked about what they would
do for perhaps some of them talked about
providing more assistance to children
some of them talked about bible studies
and everything all kinds of different
things the talent the the stage presence
it was fun yes awesome great
contributors every year when i see you
dude i love that stuff
i think it's great and saddled west
they killed it was awesome good for them
proud there too